hey there
you want to see something cool this is a
video that i shot and edited earlier in
june that is both one of my favorite
videos as well as one of my favorite
combos that i have ever written ever
been curious how i write a combo and
what goes in versus what doesn't this
time around i documented the process
meticulously and now i'm going to share
it with you drex here from drexfactor
poi sharing with you the love of boy
spinning and flow arts to benefit your
body and brain and today i'm walking you
through my process for choreographing
poi dance and how i wrote a personal
favorite before we dive in i just want
to give a quick shout out to the friends
of the channel big thanks to dark monk
fire mecca flow fests flow toys juggling
calling pyroterra light toys spin balls
and ultra poi for helping to make the
videos on this channel possible you can
learn more about all these amazing
businesses and what they're doing to
support flow artists like yourself by
checking out the links that i've got
down in the description of this video
and special thanks to non-business
friends of the channel johnny howard les
muchinski and becca beklunen thank you
all so very much for your support from
my work and my mission
so first up an obvious question where
did the idea for this combo come from
there's a dancer that i follow on
instagram named kelly erdman who's done
several different experiments showcasing
choreography that utilizes some
post-production work to stabilize the
footage around her head this makes it so
that you can easily cut to her
performing the same choreo in other
locations and the transition looks more
or less seamless i actually already
experimented with this idea earlier in
the year i shot a different combo that
was heavily based upon some choreo i'd
written previously as a test to see
whether a similar video format could
work for me
given that it's the second most viewed
video on my instagram at this point
i'd say the answer to that question was
yes so i wanted to do it again but this
time write a combo specifically for this
style of video this meant that i needed
to center it around a few basic ideas
one my head needed to move around a lot
but stay focused towards the camera as
much as possible
what makes this format work is that if
the head isn't moving but the background
is moving around it looks super trippy
but the effect isn't as pronounced if
the head isn't moving very much so just
doing a tech tree combo would completely
defeat the purpose second i needed to be
able to do this combo with rock solid
consistency i needed to nail the
placement of my poi and body parts time
and time again or the cuts between
different locations would look so
different that the effect would be lost
that meant no tricks that i couldn't
nail 100 of the time and my form had to
be nearly identical every take next the
combo had to work inside of a relatively
small area i could move stage left and
stage right but if i moved too far to
either side
i would wind up out of the frame
i'd be shooting from several meters away
with a wide angle lens so that would
definitely help but fundamentally i'd
need to stay within a pretty small area
and more importantly hit my marks within
that area time and time again finally
the combo needed to loop it needed to
end in the same place that it began so i
could create the illusion of it
operating on an endless loop
that meant writing a combo that would
return to where it started not just with
poi movements but also with where i was
on stage with those rules in mind i got
to work the combos started with two very
specific ideas and grew from there on
may 8th i started work on the combo with
a flow session in my apartment
i didn't intend to start work on a new
combo that night but two ideas came to
me that seemed irresistible to
experiment with the first idea was to
link together two tricks that i
absolutely adore but had never thought
to combine in this specific way before
point isolations and a cat versus
pendulum antibrid i realized i could
exit the cat versus pendulum off to my
right hand side by taking the moment
right before they both drop down toward
my left and instead abort the antibrid
by point isolating both poi and moving
my body over to the right the result
would feel almost like an anti-gravity
illusion with the poi left hanging there
in space but what to do next i took the
poi off to my right and started spinning
it in horizontal plane moving the hand
attached to it up and down the tether
for the poi that was still left hanging
in space
i have no idea where this idea came from
and in my head i referred to it as the
ufo and at first i had a devil of a time
doing it without tangling it with the
other tether right off the bat i thought
the ufo looked awesome and my first
thought for where this went next was to
end it with a spiral wrap high above my
head
unwrapped to a float and then dropped
the poi into a behind the back catch i
struggled real hard with the catch
though because the momentum of the poi
had changed so much with so many rapid
plane changes
i couldn't be certain of how they'd drop
and that made both the catches a
challenge to land as well as looking
pretty sloppy
i could never get the catches to look
clean even when i nailed them so i
quickly abandoned this idea on may 9th i
went to the drum circle at malcolm x
park in columbia heights and i had an
idea since the point isolations were
pulling me off to stage right i'd jump
out of the ufo back to stage left using
something resembling a butterfly kick
and a horizontal flower i also got it
into my head to attempt to behind the
back waist strap from a dead stop right
after the jump
what should come after the waist wrap
wasn't really clear so i ad-libbed a
bunch of body tracers and a behind the
head spiral wrap
the body tracers looked crude and
improvised because they were but that
jump was definitely a keeper the next
day i revisited this choreo and made one
major change i added plies to the ufo to
add some level changes i knew i got the
best results out of those head tracking
videos the more body movement i could
throw in so this would add an extra
layer of interest to this section i was
still trying to make the behind the back
waist strap work at this point and
trying out some other body tracers to
get back to the pendulum versus cap
this part really wasn't working though
and i knew that even at the time in the
week after though i got inspired by a
video of voitus dolbenko that flowtoys
had released i've long wanted to learn
some of the work that he does putting
the tether through around and under his
legs and i discovered that one of the
jumps he did in this video wasn't as
hard as i thought it was i wondered what
if i added that jump immediately after
my own jump taking the poi from high to
low as i traveled across the stage on
may 17th i spent a good portion of the
afternoon trying to add this element and
workshopping the choreo in general and
several important changes came out of it
i quickly discovered that the plies
during the ufo had created a small
problem i had a tendency to dip my
entire body with the plies and i really
wanted the static poi to remain isolated
in space
i found i got the best results if i
extended my arm as i did the plie to
compensate for the level change i did
try to keep the idea of getting into a
real bass turn from a dead stop alive by
performing a stall with a head check and
then dropping from that into a crosser
just like the waist strap from the dead
stop though it looked super awkward i
was also struggling with the question of
how to loop the choreo how to get from
the crosser back to pendulum versus cap
i tried inserting a favorite transition
from standard hand placement to
anti-bridge placement by way of while
playing anti-spin flowers and performing
a cap across the top but it didn't have
a lot of body movement to it and i
really didn't like that when i tried
adding voita's leap to my choreo it did
seem to match with the direction and
momentum of the poi
but it also just didn't look good to me
no matter what i did with it
my body positioning looked awkward and
it kind of killed the momentum of the
first jump
i realized at a certain point that i was
fighting to try and insert somebody
else's style into my own choreo and just
wound up abandoning the idea in favor of
doing something that felt more like me i
thought to replace it with a horizontal
spiral wrap above my head and perform a
short coupe to give the combo a little
bit of a rebound to head back the other
way
but what would come after to get me over
to stage right one idea was to do a kind
of chane with an extension another was a
grapevine step with a meltdown i
actually did bring part of this idea
back later on in the choreo process but
overall i didn't think as a whole it
really worked another idea i tried very
hard to make work was to drop down
coming out of that spiral wrap and
performing a little horizontal flower on
my way through
the idea here was to do a level change
to try and get more body movement out of
a video that was going to be very
heavily based in head tracking i also
experimented with a brief section at the
end where i switched to a one-handed
butterfly and briefly walked towards the
camera before doing a throw and focus
shift on the catch before heading back
upstage
i still love this idea but i knew it
wouldn't work for the type of video that
i wanted to make because i couldn't have
significant movements going down or
upstage only stage left or stage right i
might use this idea somewhere else in
the future though i really loved the
first part of this combo but i felt kind
of lost on the rest of it i put it down
for a few days but then on may 23rd i
had a breakthrough on the second part of
the choreo despite my directive to
create all original choreo for this
particular video i tried adding in a
brief trick combo that i've become quite
fond of over the years and it definitely
made something click for me in the
latter half of the combo here's what it
looked like i would do snakes in split
time same direction and then a hand
switching throw before performing a you
to stall turn and switching into zan's
diamond
not only did this incorporate a lot of
body movement in intricate tech it also
stood in stark contrast to the first
half of the combo that was dominated by
repetition i knew the repetition in the
first part of the combo built tension so
having a very rapid series of
transitions seemed like a good way to
pay off that tension and i love how this
particular set of tricks pays off by
making transitions happen in places you
wouldn't expect in particular the
transition from the udestal to zan's
diamond just feels like the momentum
should not work and yet it does so
beautifully in order to make sure i was
getting in as much body movement as
possible i resolved to keep my body
slightly crouched and essentially do
lunges to either side with my upper body
as my hands were performing the same
movements to accentuate them and make
sure enough was going on in this section
to still make it interesting when i got
to doing the head tracking at one point
i did experiment with removing the
movement back to stage right and just
switched to doing the snake to poi throw
on stage left after the leap in spiral
wrap this also meant that i would drop
out of zan's diamond into the pendulum
versus cap anti-grid and it was
definitely less than ideal
not only did it keep the combo tucked
into too tightly a small space but it
wasn't going to be very interesting when
the head tracking entered into the
picture
this could have worked if i didn't
intend to do much if any movement to
stage right or left but doing so was
pretty explicitly the purpose of doing
all this choreographing i ultimately
decided to bring back the movements to
stage right and make it travel more but
how to get from point a to point b i
knew i wanted to arrive at the snake
into hand switching throw so it was
going to be helpful to end this movement
on something that was in split time same
direction
i brought back an element of that
grapevine meltdown and just performed
the end of it i found this gave me an
opportunity to play with contrasts my
body would go from very tightly wound to
opening up broadly to each side there
was a kind of elasticity in this
transition that i really liked
compressing and expanding my body so how
to get there i was kind of surprised to
find that despite assuming that i'd have
to do some kind of zero point plane
break that i could instead more or less
bend my planes from horizontal to
vertical plane when i arrived at stage
right
this shouldn't work it should look
sloppy but somehow it didn't my best
guess as to why is that the body tracing
elements of the meltdown are helping to
smooth out the plane bend but
i'll confess i don't really understand
why this worked from a visual standpoint
but i'm sure glad that it did this was
also where i figured out how to get back
into the beginning of the combo
i decided to reference the idea that had
started it all off by stalling out of
zan's diamond and dropping both poi into
pendulums before heading back to stage
left and performing point isolations
with both poi to accentuate that return
to the beginning
in later takes i would add a chasse to
this movement to make it dancier
great way to add body movement and cool
poi moves i finished out the day with
the combo really close to what would
turn out to be the final version
my one remaining challenge was what move
to use between the spiral wrap and the
meltdown to get to stage right
that crouching horizontal flower was a
great idea but it felt so awkward i felt
like i was fighting the momentum of both
my body and my poi to get to stage right
and the results
just did not look good to me i wound up
ad-libbing some additional footwork
during the ufo plies that a part of me
is sad that i forgot to hold on to
i actually like what this could have
been but it got lost in cleaning up the
rest of the choreo and in all honesty it
was probably best to keep things simple
to make my life easier and make sure i
was more consistent between takes
i'd actually forgotten i did this until
i went back and watched all these old
videos but something real exciting
happened on my final two takes of the
combo for the day i was getting real
tired at the end of the practice session
and my mind was starting to wander i
misjudged my body momentum coming out of
the spiral wrap and rather than abort
the attempt i just went with it and
rather than crouching down with my
horizontal flower i instead exploded out
with a turn that included an arabesque
my last time to the combo i tried it
again just because it felt so good the
first time i didn't hold out hope that
this was going to produce a good result
mostly because the first time it was an
accident and i wanted this level change
to go down instead of up at that moment
also neither attempt was particularly
clean or aesthetically pleasing
but what this did have going for it was
that it worked with the momentum and if
nothing else i could see the potential
for what this could be if i cleaned it
up so as i went back through the footage
i noticed a few things that really
needed to be cleaned up for starters the
point isolations coming out of that
pendulum versus cap were a little hit or
miss
sometimes they would land and the moment
of having the poi just seemed to hang
there in space would hit
and sometimes it just looked like i was
stepping to the side with the poi and
the contrast with the anti-bread was
completely lost second i needed to be
more clear about my head movement after
going to stage right
sometimes i would focus shift to suggest
movements left or right but i wasn't
being consistent about it and with the
point of this video being tracking my
head between different takes i was going
to need to be in order to make the edits
work
i needed to make choices here and stick
with them finally as much as i loved the
chasse it also messed with my perception
of where the poi were on stage and the
point isolation was getting a little bit
lost in the process
what was coming out was looking more
like a cat eye so i needed to keep the
first parts of that movement further
over to stage right if i was going to
make that point isolation land and this
brings us to the final practice session
when all the pieces finally came
together for me knowing i'd be hitting
that turn with the arabesque i put a lot
more intention into the position of the
poi as i was doing so and finally that
movement to stage right just clicked but
there was also one other final piece of
the puzzle to put into place on one take
i had a happy accident as i was exiting
out of the chasse with the point
isolations i brought my hands and poi
around an aesthetic spin versus
extension anti-bread before dropping
into pendulum versus cap
i actually didn't even know that i had
done it until i went back to watch the
video but the moment i saw it i realized
it was a keeper
it did a great job of resetting the
combo and it contrasted beautifully
between the chasse point isolation and
the cat versus pendulum at the top of
the combo
it solved a problem i didn't even know
that i had so with all that information
in hand i went to go shoot the combo on
june 1st i used the same four locations
that i had before mainly because there's
not a lot of big walls close to where i
live that are more or less flat and
don't have a lot going on with them but
also because it was a process that i was
already used to i set up my camera an
identical distance from each wall and
shot myself performing the combo no less
than four times in a row in each
location i then imported the footage
into final cut pro and used their
built-in motion tracker to isolate my
face in each piece of footage before
editing them together and inserting cuts
between each scene and yes i set kate
bush as the background music because i
had just watched the first half of
season 4 of stranger things
i didn't choreograph this to music but i
did try to make sure that it was of an
appropriate length that a song in common
time would have around six complete bars
of music that could play over it to help
with the looping effect in the end i'm
really happy with the choreo that i
wrote and i guarantee it'll make another
appearance at some point
this was really fun to choreograph and i
hope you enjoyed this look behind the
scenes at my process for writing
choreography and making this video want
more information on how that video got
shot and edited itself leave me a
comment and let me know
maybe i'll do a follow up
[Music]
did you get anything out of this video
please make sure to like comment share
and subscribe to keep the conversation
going and to help other people find this
video this video would not have been
possible if not for the wonderful
support of all of these amazing people
right here these are my flow patrons
over on patreon and they along with the
people listed down in the description
help to make this video and all the
videos on my channel possible
thank you one and all for your support
do you like my videos do you like my
flow sessions vlogs reviews combos and
more i'm on a mission to bring poi
spinning and flow arts to the wider
world and help people connect with their
brains and their bodies so help me do it
head on over to
patreon.com drexfactorpoi and sign up
you can do that at the link in the
description or the card that just popped
up if you are watching on youtube
there you can get access to a whole host
of awesome rewards and help me along in
my mission do check that out please and
thank you thanks so much for watching
this video if you're interested in more
videos about how i create my videos and
my process for doing so i'll go ahead
and link to a playlist of videos that
cover other topics in that genre down in
the description or up on screen if
you're watching on youtube make sure to
get outside and flow today and i hope
this inspired you to play with your own
approach to creating poi choreography
have a good one and i'll see you with
the new video on wednesday
peace